nine months ago a full month after the
presidential election joe biden assured
the american people that he did not
support the federal vaccine mandate for
covid19 mandatory no i don't
think the demand to be mandatory but i
would do everything in my power just
like i don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide i'll do everything
in my power as
president united states to encourage
people to do the right thing and when
they do it demonstrate that it matters
clear enough but because his word is
completely worthless joe biden did a 180
and is demanding now that 100 million
americans give up their freedom and take
the fouchy algae and he did so in the
most cartoonishly super villainy
language possible
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week we've been patient
but our patients is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
this is not about freedom or personal
choice
this is about joe biden's patience
wearing thin
got it
well i've got two words for joe biden
and they're not mr president
i do not presume to speak for the
american people
but speaking just for us here at the
daily wire
we will not comply joe biden can go
pound sand we will pursue every legal
option available to us to ignore this
incoherent and un-american edict from on
high joe biden's speech yesterday
was the most vicious
divisive speech
i have ever heard from an american
president
about his fellow americans
it began
well you heard a little touch of it
earlier
it began with this idea of joe's
patience wearing thin look he's a
crotchety old man his patience wears
thin he doesn't he's not his he's not
old slap happy joe like he used to be
and so he he opens up the speech
vilifying americans who for whatever
reason in their prudential judgment
decided that they didn't want to get the
experimental drug for the for the wuhan
cough
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program
despite the fact that for almost five
months
free vaccines have been available in 80
000 different locations
we still have nearly 80 million
americans who have failed to get the
shot the unvaccinated overcrowd our
hospitals or over-running emergency
rooms and intensive care units
leaving no room for someone with a heart
attack or pancreatitis or cancer and a
distinct minority of americans supported
by a stink minority of elected officials
are keeping us from turning the corner
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
so 80 million americans who who refuse
to take the experimental jab for the
virus that for most people is just a
mild cold
they they are destroying the country
they are the reason people can't get
cancer treatments
not the lockdown you know remember the
lockdown the various lockdowns that
we've been in that actually prevented
people from getting cancer treatments no
it's not that it's the unvaccinated
because this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated i don't think that joe
biden would have given this speech this
vicious speech
if the number had been 160 million
he wouldn't have done that because
then you would have had half of the
country
not having been vaccinated and he
doesn't want to risk that kind of
political capital
castigating half of the country he only
wants to wait until it's a distinct
minority then he can go out and
demagogue
as he licks his finger he puts in the
area figures out which way the wind is
blowing and his word is worthless so
when he says there won't be a mandate
that's just a lie
when you want to protect yourself i
would strongly recommend you check out
ring alarm ring alarm you can protect
your home anytime from anywhere i love
it especially when i'm on the road i go
on the road a fair bit and sweet little
alice and cute little junior in our
house well i like to know that we can
keep an eye on every
square inch of our house we can know who
shows up at the door before we open that
door we can just it's all centralized
all very simple with ring alarm it's so
easy to install even i can do it
incredibly inexpensive it makes a great
housewarming gift too because you'll get
credit for a really great gift and you
won't have to shell out a ton of money
go check it out today protect your home
anytime from anywhere with ring alarm go
to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today build the
system that's right for your home have
it up and running in minutes that is
ring.com knowles
be like me i'm looking at it right now
for another relative of mine ring.com
slash knowles
so he he comes out and he says okay the
the unvaccinated they're awful people
they're evil awful terrible people
they're killing the good vaccinated
americans but
the vaccinated americans are not at risk
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covert per day for
the vast majority of you who've gotten
vaccinated i understand your anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness
even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
help me out here maybe i'm a little bit
slow maybe i just don't understand this
joe biden is saying
that there are a lot of americans who
are angry at the unvaccinated because
they have anxiety that they could get a
breakthrough case and face the serious
complications of coronavirus
and he understands that anger frankly
he's stoking that anger in this speech
but
the vaccinated americans are at
statistically no risk of coronavirus
from the unvaccinated americans
right he's saying the science is clear
you're not at risk it's over you have
a st an infinitesimally small chance of
getting a breakthrough case and of
certainly of suffering any serious
consequences from it so then why do you
understand the anger why do you
understand the frustration they
shouldn't be angry and they shouldn't be
frustrated because they're not at risk
because the people who don't want to
take the fauchiachi for whatever reason
maybe because you schmucks have been
lying to us for the past year and a half
maybe maybe
they have
a justification for that
maybe
they've got some prudential judgment
and as you admit they don't pose any
threat to the vaccinated people
but he continues to demagogue anyway
because they listen they don't pose any
threat at all but because of the massive
threat they pose we're going to make 100
million people take the shot
and
i know this is crazy look i'm not an
epidemiologist
but why is the focus
entirely on a vaccine when we're when
we're being told that the vaccines
they do work they're so wonderful
they're the greatest vaccines ever but
also they don't really work and they
don't really stop the spread and you
then you need a booster two months after
you get your original series of vaccines
but they're really really good but
they're also not that effective so
if there's so many questions about the
vaccines why not focus on
treatments we're increasing the
availability of new medicines
recommended by real doctors not
conspiracy conspiracy theorists
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals hold
on a second so what you're telling me is
that there are all these questions about
the vaccines and it took a long time to
to jump through all of the various hoops
and they're not quite as effective as
everyone told us they are and that's why
you need new booster shots and there's
still these breakthrough cases and
they're still being transmitted
and you've got a hundred and
170 to 200 million americans who have
taken that
versus 1.7 million
americans who have received the the
treatment the therapeutics that reduce
the risk by 70 that are very effective
that you're now calling calling on them
to be more widespread
why haven't you put any focus on the
treatments before why are you focused
only on this vaccine that has a lot of
questions about it
when you could just focus on the
therapeutics which seems much more
reliable
and then instead of having to
jab
shoot up every single american shut down
the economy you could just treat people
who actually have symptoms who are
actually at risk why not do that fauci
fauci has undertaken the strategy from
the beginning of his career this was a
big issue when he was dealing with aids
back in the 1980s
everybody said hey just develop some
treatments he said no we've got to focus
on the vaccine he put most of the
resources behind the vaccine we still
don't have an aids vaccine and the only
way people with aids survive is because
they take cocktails of therapeutics
decade and decade and decade of failure
and now this guy these people are going
to lie to us they're going to vilify all
of these americans and they're going to
upend
our constitutional order disgust one of
the most disgusting speeches i've ever
seen from a president
[Music]
[Music]